the Joe Rogan experience so let's bring
people up to speed what what have the
what are the latest revelations what's
the the latest in terms of what we
understand in terms of what could
possibly be fixed about human aging all
right so the fantastic answer to that
question is there are no new revelations
in terms of what we understand our
understanding seems to have been pretty
much complete already like 20 years ago
the fact that we haven't found out any
fundamental new stuff that we didn't
know before then is fantastic news
because of course it means that we're
unlikely to find anything out in the
future either it means that we are
pretty much on top of the description of
the problem and therefore it's all about
solving the problem is it possible
summarize the problem what is the
problem what causes human agent sure
that's easy so aging is simply the same
thing in a living organism like you or
me as what it is in a car or an
aeroplane or any other simple man-made
machine it's a fact of physics nothing
to do with biology that any machine that
has moving parts is going to do itself
damage in the course of its normal
operation as an intrinsic consequence of
its normal operation okay so in the same
way that a car Russ Jim is gonna bring
that microphone oh good yep yeah you
started keep it about a fist from your
face yeah so in the same way that a car
rusts or you know accumulates junk in
the oil or whatever
similarly the human body does damage to
itself and again just like a car and
airplane the human body is set up to
tolerate a certain amount of that damage
so that we can get through to the point
where we have kids before we start going
functionally downhill when they're
mentally or physically but after that
evolution doesn't care about us anymore
and therefore we are only equipped to
tolerate that much
and eventually the damage that's being
done accumulates to a point beyond what
the body fed up to tolerate and that's
when things start to go wrong and was
about to function less well what is the
difference physically between a younger
person an older person in terms of their
ability to recover from the damage of
just regular everyday live from exercise
and abuse and running around yeah all
that
so that's just one ask
the difference between a younger person
an older person so let me answer that
question by stepping back one step okay
so the difference ultimately arises from
what the body is made of at the
molecular level and failure level
the body accumulates various changes
that are chemical and biological
consequences of what the body has to do
to keep us alive from one day to the
next even starting before were born and
those changes so if I'm using the word
damage to describe those changes is
because eventually things don't work so
well so you're quite right that recovery
from injury is one thing that doesn't
work so well but so are plenty of other
things so whether it's how fast you can
run how fast you can think you know how
strongly you can grip something how fast
you can walk you know all of these
things become progressively less good
but the point is that the amount by
which they become less good is pretty
negligible until the age of 40 or 50
it's only then that the decline starts
to accelerate so what do you do in your
own life to try to mitigate that
acceleration yeah that's crazy but
you're right this is your business so
there are two reasons why I'm bad okay
the first reason is that I'm really
well-built I'm just lucky I'm just one
of those hateful people who I can eat
and drink exactly what I like and
nothing seems to happen and I don't even
need to exercise to speak of and you
know I'm for biologically far younger
than I actually am chronologically how
old you chronologically chronologically
I'm 57 how old do you think you are
biologically well I'm told that I'm a
good decade less than that this is what
I get told every time I do these tests
which I've been doing further Purse let
me see 18 years yeah so that's pretty
good news so you're lucky yeah yeah but
the other thing is you know I'm working
hard to hasten the defeat of Aging and
maybe it's a net win you know maybe the
amount that I'm hastening it is more
than the damage I'm doing myself by for
example not getting enough sleep and you
still drink booze I still drink how
often I drink probably more than the
average American what does that mean I
feel better today maybe three or four
yeah three or four beers every day
muster and
whiskey or two every day as well I'm
left so six days a week or six drinks a
day yeah
Wow one drink right now only if you have
would do everything beer do any honey
cancer we have the fake ID rinsky I only
drink actual bear not Heineken
was the actual beer well you know IPAs
things like that Oh luck bit Heineken
doesn't taste like beer of course not
I don't know I mean we didn't fuse beer
for a while but I think oh that does
lose all of his gains by actually no I
never smoke pot I mean I've experimented
with it when I was younger but it never
did anything to me
[Applause]